greg pochitis
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
my name is bert macklin yeah i'm with
the
fbi uh i hate talking
to people about things this is a
nightmare
ah i'm grouchy huh we have to support
tom
think about it as role-playing that
makes it
sexy that could be fun really
can i use a weird voice and try to freak
people out yes okay
and uh next time you see me i'll be a
stranger
hello strange person who i have never
met before
who are you i'm janet snakehole i'm a
very rich widow with a terrible secret
who are you
bert macklin fbi it was the best damn
age they had until i was framed for a
crime i didn't commit
stealing the president's rubies
now i work alone lovely to meet you i
got to admit
uh i thought your costume would maybe be
a little bit [ __ ]
how dare you
nice okay i'm ready good wait
not ready super scared andy you said you
wanted to be an action star
this is your chance okay
okay you natalie follow the action
whatever what do i have to do hold up
this butter knife to my throat and
pretend like you're holding me hostage
we're ready i don't know it seems a
little crazy
just crazy enough to work
my face my face is fine
mikhail petrov forget it macklin you're
too late
i'm sorry guys i i i need my cheaters i
cannot see and you're doing really good
you're doing really good really yeah
help me agent macklin help me he's
stolen my jewels
and now he's gonna ravish my body and he
stinks he really stinks okay
janet snako belongs to mother russia now
oh that's what you think
now i hope you like pain
taylor looks like this siberian husky is
going to be russian
off to jail hey
can i go gayle is making a roast
you think i haven't been around the
world i've been everywhere darling i'm a
very wealthy woman my husband
kept me in the finest clothes from
bergdorf goodman you see
freeze fbi go leave me alone
hit us in the air i didn't kill anybody
and i didn't burn down the middle either
my sister did but now she's been eating
my walls
nothing to see here there's only one man
for this job
bert macklin fbi i said i was
retired they said i was too dangerous
for the pawnee police department
turns out they were right and wrong
macklin you son of a [ __ ]
oh hello anne
this case just got interesting well not
just
it was pretty interesting to begin with
this case
just remained interesting
leslie are you pregnant did you or did
you not leave this positive pregnancy
test in a dumpster in the woods
hey everybody
no really okay well i'll get out of your
hair
sorry to interrupt what's that brandy
max
put this music down
[Music]
i don't know why leslie knope's on trial
and the beavers did it
beavers did it sit down i will hold
myself in contempt of the court
a few days ago in a routine campaign
stopping downtown pawnee
one leslie knope pause was attacked
play by a pie luckily it only hit jerry
so no damage was done
play the only evidence we have is a
video shot by paws
my wife april ludgate this is bert
macklin's greatest assignment
yet if you are watching perpetrator
just know that you are still at large
okay listen up folks we have a security
situation here
as you know when we reach location i
will be conducting a security sweep
also from now on we'll be using code
names you can address me
as eagle one and code name been there
done that
april is currently doing that donna is
it happened once in a dream chris code
name if i had to pick a dude
ben is eagle two oh thank god
i've been staring at this board for days
i'm so close to putting it together
there's got to be something we missed
let's go over this again the video
shows that the pie came from a high
angle
so it would have hit your face
like this don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right yeah good clean
yourself up
let's do this again all right let's go
to the video again
sweet kick leslie exits the building and
then
you get hit
[Applause]
what else do we know we know that leslie
was about 15 feet in front of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim
or leslie wasn't the target
well who then
okay that's permanent marker go find ben
get a list of everyone he's ever fired
go go
macklin you son of a [ __ ]
sewage joe ben white fired you for
sending pictures of your penis to
everyone and you've come here to pie him
little twerp has it coming oh dude i
dare you please
give me one reason to take you down i
would love
nothing oh ben sorry
all right let's go oh i did it
yeah great job agent macklin
i need you some thieves are trying to
steal the legendary snakehole sapphire
what the no that sapphire has the power
to activate the cuban missile crisis
damn it macklin i love it when you take
charge
make love to me you fool you animal
okay rain check that all right they're
here
wow look at them there you ate little
monsters
i love this you guys are the best i need
this stupid town with all these stupid
terrible people i need that birth
certificate leslie
wait here bert macklin is on the case
andy no don't worry
i can do this believe in me
it's broken
hold on listen real quick uh spell your
last name for me
got it got it nice
i also got this dude's briefcase i was
just laying there kind of a panic move
i believed in you but you should put
that back okay
say thanks chum i got those papers
delivered for you
whatever posthaste
the doctor says it's probably not
serious but it might be
oh kyle please stop talking why isn't it
bert macklin what are you doing here
and who's this sorry charlie i'm janet
snakehole i demand answers and i want
them now
please i love you no offense
but burm macklin died last night after
the tenth shot of snakejuice
okay sorry
ms snakehole
you think i'd let you get away that
easily
bert macklin may be dead but i'm his
brother
kip hackman
why wouldn't you have his same last name
shut up kyle
i know you boosted those paintings maybe
it was me
but i'll never tell you where they are
and you'll never have my body either
you